i hate intros logo rides in season 1
episode 1.
we kick things off with the introduction
of the main character shiro who finds
himself transported inside of a game
called elder tale
he had taken on his in-game character
which is a level 90 half-alph enchanter
there are numerous other players in the
city of
akiyabara who are all stuck like he is
just like in the game there's a status
screen where he finds all of his items
as well as a disabled logout button
shiro gets the idea to check his friends
list to see who else is online there are
a couple of different people online so
he goes to meet with the first of god
knows how many side characters not sugu
level 90 human guardian and pervert the
two discussed that the new expansion
called nova sphere pioneers was released
shiro remembers everything up until the
second that the
update was released and then woke up
inside the game they head off to see
what they can find out which is when
they come across waifu candidate number
one in akatsuki
downside for her is that her avatar is a
man shiro gives her a discontinued
potion that allows her to change her
gender to
a girl taking on her final waifu form as
a level 90 human assassin
we learned that npcs refer to themselves
as people of the land while players are
known as adventurers
everybody is starving but unfortunately
none of the food or drinks taste like
they should and are all extremely bland
while eating shiro gets a call from
another friend so they go to meet with
her now we get white food number two in
marielle who was a level 90 elf cleric
and the guildmaster of the crescent moon
alliance
the waifu parade continues with
henrietta a level 90 bard also in the
crescent moon guild
while talking they learned that the
inner city transport gates are offline
preventing their normal means of travel
they also inform them that all of the
other guilds have launched recruitment
campaigns in preparation for any trials
that come their way
even though they are familiar with the
game because there was an expansion just
released the monsters items and quests
could be all different marielle points
out that the debauchery tea party which
is shiro's old group that he hung out
with isn't around anymore she
recognizes that he is a huge fan of
guilds but she invites him to join
crescent moon anyways he says nope and
they leave apparently the debauchery tea
party was a well-known
unofficial guild that won some lucrative
battles with shiro
acting as their strategist after their
little meeting they head into the
archive tower forest to experiment with
the combat system on lower level
monsters
a group of level 28 briarweasel show up
and attack him there are some initial
difficulties with the system but since
they're level 90 they kill him anyways
we learned that there are 30 000
japanese adventurers as well as several
hundred thousand around the world that
got stuck in the game the day that they
were all transported into the game
became known as the apocalypse
episode 2. some dumbass dies in combat
but this confirms to the rest of the
players that it's just like in the game
and if you die you revive at a cathedral
after they're done training everybody
meets with the crescent moon again at
this point most of the local guilds have
finished their recruiting so now
everybody is just trying to figure out
who the strongest one is
it appears that some of the bigger
guilds are starting to assert their
dominance on the smaller ones
there isn't any fighting allowed in the
cities or npcs called the royal guards
appear
and kill you although they did find
workarounds to harass the smaller guilds
without triggering the royal guards
there's also been a spike of player
kills just outside of the city
newer players are being targeted as they
leave the city because they drop loot
when they're defeated this segways
nicely into them going out for training
and running into peak cares who try to
rob them
although they're outnumbered thanks to
shiro calling the shots they quickly
dismantle them
once back at crescent moon they learned
that one of the crescent moon members
had run into some trouble in the city of
susikino
and was rescued by an unknown character
muriel is planning on
sending their best members to retrieve
the girl and bring her back to safety
she wrote quickly realizes that they
won't be capable enough he also knows
that since this world is set to half
scale based on the real world it'll take
them too long to get there on horseback
after some contemplation shiro and the
others offered to go there and bring her
back for them
once outside the city shiro and natsugu
summon griffins to get them there faster
akatsuki is surprised because the
whistles that summon them are rare items
that were only given to players that
completed a special mission
episode three on their way to cischino
they arrive at a dungeon called the
depths of palm which they have to go
through because the griffins have a
limit
anyways we get our first look at the
level 19 sarah
who is the girl that they're going to
rescue we also meet the one responsible
for saving her from the thugs in the cat
bro named nyanta
they talk about how the guild bragandia
are a bunch of [ __ ] and terrorizing
everybody in susquino
over to the others whose path collapses
and shiro falls into some water then he
loses consciousness which procs a
flashback to how he was an engineering
student in college
even though he was kind of a loner when
he started playing elder tale he became
a well-known veteran
after a while a lot of people started
wanting his help with quests
and that got to be a little old this is
when he met natsuku and the other
debauchery tea party members who got him
back into playing
good news for everybody vpn's off
because ikatsuki
is also around 20. so you guys are safe
everybody gets confronted by a new
monster part of the nova sphere
expansion
it's only level 68 though so they make
quick work of it and make it out of the
dungeon
hop on over to the vergandia guild who
are a group of pkrs outside of susquino
led by the brute named demikos
he and his men are pretty ruthless and
we learned that they are also looking
for sarah and nianta
episode 4. when they arrive at suskino
shiro goes ahead of the others and meets
with
sarah roth turns out him and nyanta know
each other so he decides to go with them
back to akihabara since there's no
combat in the cities demi coss and his
men wait for them to leave and then cut
them off
shiro antagonizes demicos as well as his
right hand man in landark provoking them
to fight one on one
this leads to a duel between debbie koss
and nyanta nyanta is wearing him down
with debuffs and it isn't looking good
for demicos so he orders his men to step
in and heal him this cue's not too good
to make his appearance taunting all of
the fighters to him
he is taught allow she wrote to use his
thornbind hostage ability rooting demi
cos when a teammate cuts one of the
roots binding him it deals bonus damage
nun took combos with him to cut all the
vines just before
shira recasts the vines a second time
the coronation between the two shines as
nyanta instantly kills the second set of
vines also
this deals massive damage to demi costs
leaving him at just one health makotsky
had also taken care of landark
and his team of healers putting an end
to the fight damn because launches one
more attack but sarah jumps in to kill
him sending him back to the fountain
after that everybody starts heading back
to akihabara yeah episode 5
while camping out they learned that
niantic can cook meat that actually has
flavor
he explains that the secret is not using
the interface to create the food but
cooking it by hand
instead obviously they had tried this
but the reason they failed when they
tried is because they don't have the
chef profession
we learned that nyanta was also a part
of the debauchery tea party which
explains why their coordination was so
clean when he fought with shiro we see
the small ginger is a bit of a furry so
she wants to bang the capro walakatsuki
is going for big air in search of that
protagonist dick but
anyways later on they talk about how
shiro helped out some kids that were
siblings he had seen that the two of
them got stuck in the game also so he
figures he should probably check on them
to make sure they're okay
well heading back they get caught up in
a storm so they request one of the
people of the land to give them a place
to stay while talking to the man they
realize he has a whole backstory and
feelings which makes them appreciate the
people of the land a bit more
now we hop on over to me nori and toya
who are the kids that shiro was talking
about they had joined a lower level
guild but their leader is treating them
like [ __ ]
episode 6. once they get back everybody
at crescent moon has a party to
celebrate several return
after the party marielle and shiro
discuss how the bigger guilds are
oppressive and hogging all of the good
hunting spots while shiro and the others
were gone the smaller guilds had a
conference to discuss
banding together against the bigger
guilt but it didn't go so well because
everybody was wanting different things
we also learned that the level cap has
been raised from 90 to 100 in this
expansion so some of the guilds are
focused on leveling
some of these guilds are competing with
one another to see who can level up
faster and even using exp
potions normally only players under
level 30 can get these potions but a
group called hamlin
took in these new players saying that
they wanted to help in reality they were
just wanting to take and sell their exp
potions to the other guilds
after this conversation while walking we
learned that shiro didn't like joining
guilds because all they wanted to do was
take advantage of his veteran status
now he's kind of rethinking all of this
and wonders if there is a guild out
there for him
after a quick chat with nyanta he
decides that he should get in touch with
minori he learns that her and toyah were
recruited by hamlin but now they're kind
of enslaved there so he promises to get
them out shiro requests chris and moon
aid them to get hamlin out of akihabara
for good
not only that but he doesn't like the
state of akihabara so he promises that
he's gonna clean the city up
to get his plan underway he would need 5
million gold but even with the cress and
moon selling all of their things they
would only have around 60
000. in the last couple of scenes he
also tells him that he is officially
starting his own guild and it's going to
be called log horizon
episode 7. henrietta is an accountant so
she has an idea on how to get shiro his
5 million gold
this plan entails having all of the
members gathering ingredients from
nearby hunting grounds
after that they open a stall that sells
food with
actual flavor because they're the only
ones who had figured out how to make the
food taste good again it's a huge hit
and the news spreads throughout the city
after their first day they had already
earned 43
776 gold but that means it'll still take
another four months to get the 5 million
gold that shiro is looking for
later that night shiro and nyanta go to
meet with their old friend sojiro theta
who was a part of the tea party also
now he's the guild leader of the caravan
of the west wind
even though their guild is on the
smaller side they are still one of the
more powerful guilds
so jiro acknowledges that circumstances
in akihabara are less than ideal so he
agrees to help in their plan
episode 8 marielle and henrietta meet
with yet another new face in karashin
he is the leader of the third biggest
merchant guild called
shopping street eight they settle on a
deal creating a bigger supply chain to
help support the crescent moon burger
business
we then get a flashback of when me nori
and toyah were first brought into the
world
they were quickly ambushed and robbed of
all of their valuables so they needed
somebody to get them back on their feet
that's the reason they joined hamlin but
now they're just slaves back to marielle
and henrietta who also meet with
michitaka
and roderick these are the leaders of
the other top two merchant guilds ahead
of shopping street 8 and also potential
investors
while talking shiro gets brought up who
apparently has earned the title
of villain in glasses further peaking
the investors interest
they make it known that they're looking
for 5 million gold to make the deal
happen
it hasn't made clear to the investors
where the 5 million gold will be going
though
although they do promise that once the
operation they are funding comes to its
conclusion they will come out with all
of the details
the merchants figured that they're
probably funding a massive quest
as a part of the new expansion so the
payout from this quest could be huge
as a bonus she also offers to give up
all their secrets cookbooks and recipes
that their chefs had come up with that
gives the food its flavor
this is more than enough and all of them
are eager to cough up their portion of
the dough
in the last couple of scenes we see that
some of the major guilds have been
invited to a conference being held by
shiro and marielle
episode 9. starting with the warrior
guilds we have ddd with 1543 members
next is the black sword knights with 186
members honesty 743 members
and the brigade of the west win having
64 members
there are also the crafting guilds whose
time is spent amassing items or selling
them in town
this includes marine agency with 2547
members
roderick merchant guild with 1881
members
shopping street 8 with 669 members i see
what they did there
granddale with 31 members and radio
market with 21 members
then we have the support killed and
crested moon alliance with 24 members
and of course we all know the newest
guild in log horizon having four members
these guilds were selected to be the
voice of each respective guild type with
the strongest warrior and crafting
guilds
on the other hand crescent moon
granddale and radio market are there to
be the voice of the smaller guilds
shiro makes it clear that the meeting is
being held to improve living conditions
in akihabara the silver swords leader
isn't having any of that [ __ ] since he
thinks it's a waste of time that won't
go anywhere shiro brings up susquino's
living conditions with the biggest guild
harassing everybody around them he
suggests implementing some laws to avoid
this happening in akihabara breaking
these laws would result in banishment
from the city
or being forced to disband their guild
everybody's quick to point out that
lockhorizon doesn't have the power to
keep the bigger guilds in line though if
a major guild said [ __ ] the system it
could threaten an all-out war
this promise she wrote to unveil his ace
in the hole he tells everybody that as
of
this moment he is now the sole owner and
administrator of the guild building zone
using his 5 million gold to purchase it
now normally you wouldn't be able to do
this but shiro had noticed that
since the apocalypse previously
unavailable property purchases had
become available
because he's the administrator if he
puts anybody's name on a blacklist they
will be unable to get into anything in
the guild hall there's also the fun fact
that creating leaving and joining guilds
are all done through the guild hall
not only that but the bank is also
inside the guildhall which is the only
truly safe place to keep all of your
loot sure they could switch
towns but with the transport gates
offline travel to other cities is almost
impossible now we hop on over to
hamlin's guild hall where minori antoia
follow shiro's orders to try and escape
the hamlin guild has combat turned on in
their guild hall
resulting in a fight despite this they
still find an opening and managed to get
inside the main guild building all of
the other members that were oppressing
them are either blacklisted or handled
by katsuki and natsugu
and in the last couple of scenes we see
that the guilds finally come around to
the idea and start working together
forming the new round table alliance
episode 10. keeping true to their word
shiro tells everybody the secret to
cooking food with flavor
don't use the command menu prepare the
ingredients like you would in real life
and be a chef
once they start thinking about it though
these conditions can apply to other
things as well
with this in mind shopping district 8
was able to make a steam engine which
was never available in the elder tail
game this is an interesting revelation
because it means that players with high
enough profession skill levels just need
the proper materials and they can invent
things that weren't originally a part of
this world
the realization marks the start of a
technological revolution new products
means new buyers and this will spur on
the economy as well as give people goals
to work towards
the next topic is public safety
everybody agrees that there should be
combat areas to encourage competition
on the other hand shiro wants to
implement laws against p
king in lower level zones outside of the
city people are also given the rights to
join and leave guilds as they please to
avoid another hamlin type guild
now the group comes across his first
controversy when shiro suggests that the
people of the land need to be treated
better as well
he goes on to explain that they aren't
just npcs anymore if you talk to them
they're basically real people
while adventurers need them working in
the guild buildings and markets the
people of the land don't necessarily
need the adventurers
there's also way more people of the land
so if they don't change how they're
governed there could be backlash from
them or even war after the conference
was finished the news of the newly
formed laws are spread to everybody
in akihabara we also learned that the
hamelin members had all fled from the
city all of the noobs that were being
taken advantage of in the guild end up
joining chris and moon now we get a look
at log horizon who had renovated an old
building to be their new home
no one surprised toya and me nori end up
joining log horizon
in the last couple of scenes we see that
people of the land answering to lord
sergiot seem to be keeping tabs on the
round table
and shiro we also get a look at his hot
granddaughter
in lady lancia episode 11.
everyone sets up a training camp for
noobs under level 40.
before that can happen though akiyabara
gets visited by a messenger from lord
sergiot
he's apparently a high lord of eso's
league of freedom cities
in elder tells japan is called yamoto
and is divided into five major
territories
the league of freedom cities of eso is
an alliance of
lords that rule over eastern japan these
lords have invited the round table to
attend their next gathering of allied
nobles
while shiro thinks it's a good idea to
start networking with the people of the
land it could also result in the round
table getting caught up in their
politics
they decide that ddd's leader krusty
will represent the warrior guilds at the
gathering
michitaka will represent the merchants
and shiro is just going because he's the
only one with a brain
their main goal is to learn how much the
npcs have changed since the apocalypse
meanwhile the training camp is going on
at the same time but it's all filler
kante except for the new character and
rundle house code
the representatives arrive at the palace
of eternal ice
they meet with the people of the land
and sergio with both sides probing each
other for information
meanwhile the training camp everybody
set into a dungeon episode 12.
the people of the land had also taken in
the adventurous cooking methods
further confirming how much change they
are influencing in the world they
speculate that the people of the land
are seeking
information on the ambitions of the
adventurers as well as the political
aspirations of the round
table even though it seems clear that
they're nervous about the change of
behavior and the adventures it's likely
after the first meeting that they've
calmed down a bit shiro predicts that
their next play
is getting the adventurers to work for
them he needs to know what they're
thinking though so he sends akatsuki to
spy on them over to the noobs who make
their first dungeon run they don't know
what they're [ __ ] doing so they have
trash formations and tactics
when they get attacked by some skeletons
they get [ __ ] on and have to retreat
and in the last scene we see that
lynessia has caught the eye of krusty
i'm gonna be doing part two and you can
find that on the left side whenever i'm
finished with it or you could check out
all the log horizon recaps in the
playlist on the right side you can also
find the links in the description below
and the only thing i hate more than
intros is
outros